[Musique]
ôtez maroni comment il est alors au
stade aujourd'hui dans un barber shop
son propriétaire a pu lancer son affaire
grâce otage le tremplin pour l'activité
des jeunes
allez si toi aussi tu cherches en
tremplin pour lancer sa première
activité suis moi
[Musique]
nous sommes ici au port dans le barber
shop de johan carreaux pike il a pu
lancer son activité grass otage le
tremplin pour l'activité des jeunes
grâce à ce dispositif il a piqué son
entreprise et s'insérer dans la vie
professionnelle
allez on va le rencontrer
[Musique]
bonjour on les note barber shop dandine
ou comment le tage et a aidé à le mettre
en place le times a aidé des gens
financer le matériel important les
chaises barbu le bac à shampoing
également les tondeuses study produit
très important pour débuter l'activité
tu dis c'est une aide financière à
quelle hauteur de paix c'est une aide à
hauteur de 8000 euros et toi tu savais
des axes exister commenté été réorientés
vers le tage alors j'ai été orienté vers
le talent par un compte et que je
connais très bien je travaillais à
savannah dans la boutique de gestion
alors rejoignent je vois qu'on est
nombreux lots concernant vous êtes cette
coiffure aujourd'hui j'imagine que ça
n'a pas toujours été le cas alors des
gens n'a commencé l'activité à 3 est
aujourd'hui bas a mené un set j'aimerais
déjà remettre mon équipe et mon projet à
venir aussi c'est du mas talent et sur
toutes les régions et les remercie johan
mais affirme et bonne continuation pour
n'être aussi beaucoup
le tâche est un excellent moyen
d'insertion professionnelle pour les
jeunes en recherche d'emploi grâce à
cette aide financière les frais liés à
la création ou à la reprise d'une
entreprise sont couvertes par le
département en tant que chef de file de
l'action sociale la collectivité
accompagne ainsi ceux qui n'ont pas
accès aux crédits bancaires classiques
bonjour monsieur la holding bonjour
alexandre alors quel est l'objectif de
ce dispositif alors le dispositif temps
plein pot l'activité des jeunes le taz
est un dispositif qui est là pour
accompagner les jeunes qui sont en
insertion professionnelle et en
recherche d'emploi et qui veulent créer
leur propre emploi par la création
d'entreprise et quels sont les critères
pour en bénéficier alors pour en
bénéficier il faut que le jeune ait
moins de 31 ans qu'ils soient donc en
recherche d'emploi et donc mis en
activité ni en étude et qui passe par un
des membres du réseau croît chance pour
faire sa demande d' aide aux
départements et quels sont les démarches
à effectuer donc il faut que le jeune
s'adresse à un des membres du réseau pas
chance est également vous avez deux
financeurs qui peuvent aider au montage
donc du plan de démarrage de
l'entreprise initiative rien
entreprendre qui fait des prêts à taux
zéro plus perdre éventaires la 10e
réunion qui fait du microcrédit
professionnel à la règle une fois que le
demandeur s'adresse à ces organismes une
et un dossier à remplir
tout à fait une fois que ce dossier est
rempli avec l'aide donc d'un mot d'un
des membres du réseau point chance le
dossier économique et est complet cette
demande est adressée ensuite au
département pour attribution merci
monsieur la ligne merci alexandre
en plus de cet accompagnement financier
le département assure également un suivi
post création de chaque dossier les
entrepreneurs peuvent ainsi compter sur
les agents de la collectivité ses
partenaires dans l'évolution de leur
activité une relation humaine qui assure
aux jeunes chefs d'entreprise une pleine
conscience bourgeoise bon jeu thierry
alors comment se passe votre entreprise
depuis sa création alors depuis la
création l'entreprise à créer de
l'emploi paul le jeune à l'arrivée les
galets ne sonne pas très facile en 2020
on a été élu mais à salon de la réunion
elle a des meilleurs salons de la
réunion jeudi justement parfois
j'aimerais remercier mon équipe pour
remercier le département est également
remercier nos clients
bravo pour votre parcours et votre
réussite
je vous dis à très bientôt jouer merci
beaucoup
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'information concernant le tremplin à
l'activité des jeunes n'hésitez pas vous
avez toutes les coordonnées qui
s'affiche sur votre écran le département
des générations c'est fini si vous
souhaitez revoir cet épisode ainsi que
les précédents rendez vous sur nos sites
et nos réseaux sociaux quant à moi je
vous retrouve très vite pour un nouvel
épisode à bientôt
nous sommes la sainte marie à la maison
d'accueil familial la catalan team ici
réside calcul un grand monde qu'on aime
tant tous sont accompagnés et soutenus
par des accueillons qui s'occupe bien de
24 sur 24 est venue et la beauté de
l'endroit je pense qu'ils doivent se
sentir bien ici
[Musique]